black history month comes to a close
this weekend but at the same time one
chapter of texas's civil rights legacy
is opening back up a long-suppressed
book about politics and race in dallas
is growing in popularity
even has its own twitter handle cbs news
producer rodney hawkins shows us why the
resurgence of the accommodation
is so important to so many it was
as if the civil rights movement had
never happened
retired columnist jim shoots is shocked
by his first book's newfound fame
after it was originally canceled i feel
like my book is this
weird stone tablet
that somebody found i mean it's being
bought on
amazon for hundreds if not thousands of
dollars which is crazy
i hope nobody pays that money shoots
wrote the accommodation in 1985. he says
publishers dropped a controversial book
shortly after its release for fear of
retaliation
it chronicles the bombings of black
dallas homeowners integrating a white
working-class community in the 1940s and
50s
and the deal made to stop desegregation
okay we're going to build a really nice
new
suburban style residential development
for the black
middle and professional business class
it'll be segregated of course
this is the white establishment speaking
to the black leadership
you guys are going to back off all this
integration
stuff and the black leadership basically
said great
that neighborhood is hamilton park
resistance to integration persisted
decades later
dallas is not alone in facing changes
city leaders used every tool
to ease racial tensions including a film
narrated by cbs's own
walter cronkite in 1961.
dallas is a good city and we want to
keep it that way
together we will show america
the dallas way reverend peter johnson of
the southern christian leadership
conference was a source for the book
he came to dallas for a brief assignment
and never left
i had been told before i got here
whatever you do
don't help the black community in dallas
that's shocking to hear
why would someone say that this was the
only black community in america
that officially boycotted a speech by dr
king
dr martin luther king jr only gave one
speech in seven years to a dallas church
youth group
he finally came back in 1963 to a
divided city
11 months before the assassination of
president john f kennedy
reverend johnson's boss at the time
andrew young had a sobering message for
the 23 year old before coming to dallas
in 1969.
his words were they killed the president
of the united states and dallas figured
they'll kill you now on that
this is the history hiding in the pages
of the accommodation
and why dallas county commissioner john
wally price
fought to republish it how would you
describe the book
real
and no change currently yeah when you
look at the
the economics do you realize you know
what i fight from this podium
is i'm still talking about inclusion
and diversity and being able to
participate
i'm glad to see people just being able
to get their hands on
the thing the book after more than three
decades
will be republished later this year and
comes at a time when many question why
the city is still
racially divided when this regeneration
of interest in my book started 10 years
ago i
just didn't get it at all why were you
surprised
by it well i just figured the book was
forgotten over and done with
plus all the people who wanted to talk
to me about it
were young like 20 and 30 somethings
the 75 year old is excited to give these
new readers historical context
i actually asked my wife at one point i
said if a guy
my age gets suddenly optimistic is that
one of those seven
deadly warning signs for her issues
[Laughter]
and she said you're not that optimistic
he's still a skeptic
but this time he's hoping dallas makes
an accommodation for a brighter future
for cbs this morning saturday rodney
hawkins dallas texas
you know my grandmother's from dallas i
have lots of friends from dallas and it
was it was such a separate city
for people and people you know rose to
the occasion but
separately i think you have to
understand we've said this so much but
you really do have to understand what
has happened in the past if you want to
change
the present and as you talked about
that's still going on right now
right and hey great job rodney all right
nice to see rodney hawkins with the
piece there good job buddy